this is a production of Cornell
University
it's a real pleasure today to beginning
with a unique topic and having Barbara
Laing join us restaurant owner schooner
chef University lecturer career advisor
and founder of the etiquette factor
Barbara has been providing support and
counsel for more than 30 years early on
she was a Napa Valley Winery culinary
director hosting hundreds of dining
events and establishing a reputation as
a gracious and entertaining host for the
past two decades Barbara has been
advising Cornell University students on
their personal and professional paths
once described as a blend of Betty
Crocker and Bette Midler loves to inform
us with humor and grace and shares her
belief that once you know the rules of
proper protocol for particular settings
you can then figure out how to artfully
break them Barbara's most recent
adventures include going across the
country with her husband and a 1984
westphalia campervan visiting over 10
national parks and sailing around the
world with semester at sea as the adult
lifelong learning coordinator Barbara
has two daughters the eldest Rachel some
of us know she graduated from our Plant
Sciences program in 2009 so I'm going to
pass these around the room they may
inform some questions you have later on
I think I'll just do a chunk on each
side here and we'll make sure that we
get one of these to those of you and
Geneva so that you'll
further ado thank you well thank you and
hello hello
you can leave whatever you want I won't
be hurt well I really am delighted that
you all are here and thank you whenever
I hear that bio I think that I'm really
old they go the 30 years the decades are
on it and there's a book called 150 food
jobs I've had 43 of them which means
either I'm really old I can't keep a job
or I get distracted by shiny objects and
I think that a combination of all three
of those but I do want to be able to
talk about the first thing I want to
talk about are toilets be cup and the
reason for that is that I went
downstairs you have a unusual building
when a woman needs a restroom on the
fourth floor and it's a little bit of an
obstacle course to get in there so
Marshall said just go down the stairs
turn around go down the hallway up
behind your left and you'll find it I
immediately got lost as soon as I got
out of the stairwell and I'm standing
there and a woman came up to me and she
said can I help you
and I said does it look like I need to
go to the bathroom but that was courtesy
all right that was her showing me where
the bathroom was
which brings me to Japan now you're
going to find that as I am talking it's
sort of like putting your seat belt on
is that I'm going to start going down a
path and then I am going to get
distracted and I'm going to go down
another path I might go down another
path but I will come back to the major
Avenue again so just kind of follow
along the handout that you have is kind
of like a road map but it's also like a
takeout menu so if you see something on
there that you really would like me to
be able to touch upon I really do
encourage all of you to be able to just
raise your hand and be able to interact
so that I'm not just a talking head up
here I was on semester at sea and I was
the adult lifelong learner and if you
want to learn how to be able to interact
with people live with
on a ship for four months there are 500
students aboard semester at sea and then
there were also 60 to 80 adult lifelong
learners I was the coordinator for the
lifelong learners and there is something
when you deal with people and the idea
is that you want to be able to create an
experience so that it's memorable to
them and it's about how do you take 60
people so it be a group like this every
day and making sure that everybody is
getting what it is that they need and
the way that you do that I'll be talking
about today is kind of getting that
awareness but back to Japan and toilets
because toilets do seem to rock my mind
a little bit these days the reason I
want to talk about Japan is that if you
want to learn about courtesy you go to
Japan anyone here from Japan a
remarkable country for people who know
about courtesy and politeness and I
might be saying it wrong so if you could
please try to dispel 10y a courteous
politeness Tenay like the word Nene
thank you so teeny
it means courteous or polite and it also
means in Japan to be able to act with
respect to people and their toilets
actually do this if you've never been in
a toilet stall in Japan you sit down and
there is a console I mean there is
basically an amazing amount of options
that you have when you go to the
bathrooms at Cornell you can see you
know you know you don't look at the
bathroom stall when you're walking by
you can have why I love to see whether
it's used or not so you go underneath
but we have wide openings that are
astonishingly revealing
you want them to be well in Japan
they're entirely closed and then you can
actually you can press these buttons so
that there are sounds so you know if
you're having a little trouble and it's
a large bathroom you just press a button
and it's a toilet flushing it's just the
sound of the toilet flushing and all of
a sudden if you're loco there's a warmer
to it maybe that little drying there's a
dryer to it
I'm not kidding and there's also one
button because a friend of mine on the
ship pressed it because you didn't know
what it was and the police arrived but
it is all about accommodating somebody's
needs now I'm in your handout there's
something that I call item called
Malcolm Gladwell calls it called fin
slicing I don't know if you know what
that is or not but it used to be that it
would take people anywhere from 15 to 20
minutes to basically make an assessment
about you and then they said no you know
like seven minutes then I was at two
three minutes it's now down to five to
seven seconds that without us even
knowing it we have internally made an
assessment about somebody and it's gonna
take a long time they say it's going to
take about 200 pieces of information in
your brain to convince you that you were
wrong all right so whatever that is that
person's a jerk right there for whatever
reason you have decided that in your
subconscious it's gonna take you now a
while to be able to reverse that opinion
because we don't like to admit building
our subconscious that we might have been
wrong
so thin slicing is really about creating
that first impression so part of this is
about how do you go ahead and do that
and if you look at that handout that I
have is a handout that they're getting
and you'll see that there's a picture of
two twins a pair of twins and that
they're identical here is the same
the same headband everything is the same
but what's different one person is
smiling and that is really about what's
called emotional contagion in other
words that when someone is looking at
somebody else oh I'm looking at a room
of people you are going to gravitate
towards the person who looks as though
they're engaged look as though they're
smiling oh you're gonna reflect that
they're doing someone smiles at you you
smile back at them again if someone is
frowning you're not gonna keep on
smiling because you're probably gonna
kind of absorb their reaction so this
idea of which twin would you want to be
the smiling one or the not smiling one
now this also brings 8/2 when you in a
group like this and I'm gonna jump
around a little bit last semester in the
spring I went to a panel and there was a
professor from Cornell excuse me she was
Landscape Architecture and she was
nervous
and I remember just sitting there and
there was a man in the front seat and
there he was on his little smartphone he
was just picking away entirely
self-absorbed and she is talking to the
group and I just know I was enjoying it
and that it was over and then I was that
a green star and I saw her maybe a week
later and I said you know I was at a
panel discussion you were at it I really
enjoyed your presentation on urban
architecture of gardening she said
you're the woman with the friendly face
people pick up on it and it wasn't like
I'm like this the whole time and you
know you're not that bobbing head in the
back of a car that creature but it is
the idea of what is it that you are
going to be sending out to people now
when I do presentations and I talk about
etiquette when I ask people when you
hear the word etiquette what do you
think and people have said I think of
matters I think of politeness one person
said I think of the Queen one other
person said I think of corsets I have no
idea what that means I don't want to
know what that means
but etiquette Lady Gaga right here is a
person and I'm being quite serious that
is a good representation of etiquette if
you take a look at the picture there's a
photo they have and it is of the Queen
of England and of Lady gaga and if you
look at the face of the Queen of England
what is she doing she is smiling and why
is that because Lady Gaga one has
clothes on and two Lady gaga she's
curtsey and bowing to the Queen in other
words Lady Gaga is acting in a way that
is making the Queen comfortable
etiquette is about showing respect and
acknowledgement and appreciation for
another person
that's what etiquette is and you know I
when I went across country we were in
the Grand Tetons and in the Grand Tetons
they even had and I brought it here they
had a little handout and it's about
bears and it is about bear etiquette it
literally says bear etiquette and what
do you do when you meet a bear and then
they go ahead and they tell you not much
I said they go ahead they tell you what
it is you should do and am I thinking
they might think of the wildlife and
then I do think of Lady gaga I think
she's on stage you know she is going to
a certain audience and she's acting in a
way that her little monsters or whatever
they're called she know she's acting in
a way that won't disappoint them you
know and it is about her knowing the
people and that she's shifting her
behavior depending upon the people that
she's with and that's what it shows with
her and the Queen of England it's not
about being um inauthentic it's about
thinking how can I act so I make the
other person feel comfortable
that's what etiquette is and the other
part that matters the protocol is there
that expected behavior that people
expect with one another
now before I came here today I got two
books I've I have a library of books
that is love reading about this stuff
and there are two books that I bought
and I just wanted
because it was interesting they're both
by single white men from New York
one is a lawyer and one is right and the
lawyer is Philip count gallon ins and
probably pronouncing his name wrong but
if you ever get the New York Times in
the sunday section he does the advice
column he's an economist and it's really
kind of funny because everything that he
talked about he uses graphs but
everything is very sort of laid out
here's the x-axis y-axis and all that
but it's a bad sound about Oh what for
should you use what should you do here
it's about how do you act so it's the
most appropriate and the book is first I
thought here's a thin slicing lion
guilty of this all the time
I read his column and I read the book it
up little snarky sarcasm every time that
he is writing his love columns I was a
quip and then I watch his website and
then I found out that his father
committed suicide and then I started
reading the back story and all of a
sudden you realize if there's a lot more
to someone than what you're just seeing
so don't always jump to those
conclusions about someone's behavior
until you know the whole story about
them and that was sort of my own lesson
of whoops did it again made a judgement
and you know I need to and I'm not
saying that because he had this horrible
tragedy occur in his life but I'm just
saying that the guy did not fit my
immediate impression when I started to
read about him and it says someone else
put it you know putting on your
orthopedic shoes and which means I stand
corrected and that is written guys
and that is written by one man and I
mean I didn't really like Phillips Brook
as much as this man and I know what I'd
love the title of book and the title of
book is would it kill you to stop doing
that this is done by Henry Alfred and
that this is a great book and it's a
great book because it's done by a writer
so if in fact you at all interested in
learning and just reading more about
this
may I suggest a book by someone who
actually knows how to write really well
and I'm gonna be quoting him a lot just
because he is so so good at what he does
but as I'm going down I want to be able
to talk about what the the Park Rangers
talked about who commuted you got muted
okay okay thank you we actually didn't
do that on purpose
are we all back are we back I think so
can you wave if we're back yeah you're
gonna make sure I just want to make sure
a couple of things I want to be able to
say about another author because I up
all these ways I just want to be
reminded of this then another author and
his name was Pam Fiorini and he is a
professor of literature at John Hopkins
and he started what's called this
civility project and that he is
professor of Italian literature and he
said and I really like this he said the
way in which you know and how you should
assess your day is whether or not are
you contributing to somebody's misery or
you lessening the burden of living now
that's a little dramatic in the way it
said a character I know is that man
but if you think about it as the way in
which that you interact with people are
you part of the problem
are you part of the solution and a lot
of that can even come off in body
language and I'll give you an example I
never hear listen to the dog whisperer
no the dog was first staged in Milan
like if you don't know man this is a
remarkable story of a man who came to
this country didn't know the language at
all but he had this amazing connection
with dogs he's now a multi-millionaire
and then he trains dysfunctional dogs so
he knows that if something's wrong the
dog he can just connect with them and so
they did a study on him and
dance/movement experts watch Cesar
Millan and because they want to know
happy this five-foot-two man I have such
command and they called it phrasing and
it's body language and it's a
combination of gesture and posture in
other words when you are meeting with
somebody you're making an impression the
body language is remarkable as part of
that way of assessing somebody so if
someone is walking in like this I mean
clearly it is somebody that is not
feeling particularly confident or happy
whatever Cesar Millan walks in with his
upper half his body his shoulders back
and he walks with intent and he walks in
a way in a room so that at least the
dogs pay attention but I'm saying to
think about your body language when you
are meeting with people nvi I want to
also talk about going to grab this chair
for a moment because when you are
speaking with somebody and men seem to
do this and I don't worry I'm gonna I'm
gonna rag on the women too but but
advancement really what are you gonna
say about the man
if that sometimes man when they're in a
conversation and I think everybody can
see me and I just had this in a meeting
with somebody and it was an official
professional meeting and this is how the
man is not particularly a professional
way to be sitting and I doubt if
presidents Gorton came into that
gentleman's office whether he would be
sitting that way with the president so
it really is something of how it is that
you're going to sit with someone and
even an audience like this when you
think about it though and in a classroom
you know when you and you're sitting and
even if you're really tired and you're a
student and you're sitting and you are
just exhausted and you could have lots
of reasons being exhausted but the thing
is to realize that the person up front
doesn't know those reasons and that when
they're standing the room and they see
someone that is in physical state that
clearly is looking like they're not
engaged those impressions are really
getting mixed into their heads so it's
for you it's not a one-way in Europe
that way I'm always amazed but you can
though there are company recruiters here
on campus and that it's as though the
students think that you can't see them
right because they're in a suit but
they're still like so just to recognize
that that whole body language does say
something about you and because this is
about courtesy it's about the idea of
anticipating or giving people and I like
to think of as unanticipated value you
know is if something that you can do
listen I'm going to give you just a
scenario of walking into an office a
daily walk into the office right and
you're walking in today I drove it drove
it was a toll booths I had to get a
parking ticket parking pass got to talk
to you about the parking
and the woman came accredit coaching
take my credit card I'm waiting waiting
my window isn't opening so I cast and
I'm in the slush she can't make it work
she's another creditor I can't make it
work I have a choice I have control over
my attitude now for those who that are
holding up to the Rabanne magazine there
used to be a little strip and there'd be
a little bubble and that bubble would be
what I'm thinking and it would be quite
different than what I'm speaking today
it seems that there's not always that
particular filter going on and that we
feel like it's okay to like let it be
known how I feel well you don't you
don't need to let people know how it is
that you're feeling it's called wearing
your whether Stephen Covey calls it
wearing your whether Stephen Covey wrote
the book with seven effective habits for
people or live happily ever after but
the idea is that just because you might
not be having a good day you don't need
to let everybody else know that you're
not having a good day what do you like
true when you walk into an office you
walk into a classroom whatever that
might be Danny Meyer who about studied
the table who was like one of the
premier hospitality goes in this country
has fabulous restaurants because they're
so good at customer service
he calls it stumping just because you
are having a bad day you don't need to
be spraying everybody else around you so
then now it stinks for everybody so I'm
standing there in the slush not getting
my credit card done I have a choice I
can either be hey there's a car behind
me I'm in a rush can you can you please
figure this out or put another credit
card I mean it's that attitude it's that
whole idea of the attitude and we do
this all the time we do it we get a cup
of coffee we have the headphones in and
all of a sudden we're getting a cup of
coffee
and that person is anonymous right you
give the coffee you going out it's that
idea of being engaged with whoever is
right in front of you it's taking not
just turning the music off it's like
taking the headphones out of your ears
so you can look at
and say thank you and then you can go
back or you on the phone hold on for a
minute and you look at someone and you
say thank you people have these little
Chrissy's that they kind of forget
because there's a rush that some people
think that etiquette is elitism
etiquette is for people who are snobby a
it is about manners that are about
interaction with people and it's about
recognizing that we have differences
that we all have differences and if you
acknowledge those differences well then
the manners and the etiquette is about
how can you avoid miscommunication how
can you avoid not being misunderstood
which is why even if our in the same
group of people that would just like me
right there were all women 57 years old
and they were I have Jewish from Long
Island and and then we were all in a
room together we would still be
completely different there are a lot of
things in common but we're still
completely different so it's not just
I'm not talking culturally oh if you're
with somebody from other punch no I mean
with anybody is that it's that idea of
how do you have that kind of
communication that's gonna be going on
so you walk in the office I'm back in
the middle of the day but you walk in
the office and there's a meeting that
you're gonna have to go to so you can
have a typical meeting people come in
and they want is seated down and someone
new comes in the room if anybody comes
new to the room and even when I came
around here when I was introducing
myself if someone walks up to you to
shake your hand yes stand up
it's just courtesy for you to stand up
and shake hands rather than just
remaining yourself sitting down it's
gender neutral when you I used to go to
a meeting and a woman would be up to
posted and that's what she went right
from notes on so what do you think that
tells the person who's running the
meeting and they've got a little one
inch by one inch posted that she is
basically sending the message I don't
think there's very much that I would
need
or the person who has their blackberry
and I love this everyone comes in with
their PDAs and they slap them on the
table like they're like you bore me for
a second don't to it going now you know
I can't say what's right and what's
wrong because you're gonna find that in
any situation the culture of the people
in the room is gonna dictate what's
gonna be appropriate but that's what's
key the key is you got to know what's
gonna be appropriate depending upon
who's in the room with you now in the
meanings that I would have to attend it
was not appropriate for this one young
person the rest of us being of an older
age and generation let me keep on
checking their messages the whole time
because it was that whole idea of
disengagement and it's a lunch meeting
here's another minute easy to go to I
would all be their big lunch and there's
one woman and she would have her
sandwich and she would go ahead and she
would take a bite of that sandwich and
it would always be eyesores always
peanut butter and jelly on on white
bread because it was nice and soft and
it kind of just stuck together and how
do I know this because I was able to
watch it because as she took the bite
she keep on talking and then she just
pick up that sandwich again you know
laughs but I would be events and this
was a all true stories but this one
young man took his fork and he stabbed
his food and he lifted an entire piece
of lamb
now you know we left this was a really
nice young man he had no idea that what
he was doing was not typical for the
people that were at that table so the
idea that there is some protocol that
people need to be able to understand so
that people don't feel less confident
they don't feel uncomfortable with it so
I'm gonna just go here my little cheat
sheet here as I'm moving on down here so
I don't forget oh here's something I'm
in regard to courtesy and that is
introducing people how many times are
you talking with one person another
person comes up and the screen goes
blank and you know your your screen of
the brain goes blank they're walking you
go I know I know this person I know I
know this person retrieval retrieval
retrieval and it's just coming up blank
you know whatever it is that is not an
excuse not to introduce people because
you're gonna find that people you want
to be a benefit to other people if you
can't remember someone's name here are a
few hints for you if I don't know the
person I'm with I immediately say
introduce yourself all right and they'll
go ahead or I'll say have you two had an
opportunity to meet you can't do that
the person just came off a plane from
Australia they've never been to the
United States my name and employ but you
can always you know say to somebody I'm
sorry I'm having a bad day
can you please help me out that's
Barbara and then they'll go ahead and
say their name another thing that I'll
do is that if I am going ahead and
introducing somebody and I introduce
them I try and find something that's
common between the two of them I try and
find something so they can talk about
with one another this is particularly
really good if you're at any kind of
reception or party that you're being
able to be a connector you know that you
know two people who really enjoy knowing
one another so being a benefit
remembering names so this is this is not
easy but there I roll moment as
immediately already she's oh I know I
know
you will find that remembering names so
someone says their name and this is what
you're supposed to do so let's repeat
the name I can do that part and they
walk away and it's like a bubble and it
just goes by so there was this great
article in The New York Times and it was
called life you think that the mind
I have the name of a mind changing game
but it's basically about a reporter and
he was going to study how people who met
with numbers it was a front cover of
magazine story and he decided well it
was really diligence right it was not
inherent gift that somebody had but it
would be you know people trained
themselves so he decided well I'll train
myself and he went to the experts well
the end of the story was he became the
champion which was a barber boy and you
learned how do you remember people's
names was the transferable skill from
this and what you do is that you meet
somebody and then you immediately make
an association so you've heard that
before but the key you make it really
weird strange it is the easier it will
be for you to remember that name and so
that is another thing for you to be able
to do is to make that Association and it
is a skill there's no doubt about it is
that practice I'm just starting small on
license plates I try and remember those
but it is something to be able to
introduce people you introduce somebody
and when you go ahead it's always nice
to introduce the person of higher
authority first it's not really that
important the whole idea is that if
you're being genuine is the most
important but if you can remember to
always say the most important person's
name first that you're introducing them
so I would go ahead and if I were going
to be introducing oh I don't know
raylene to Marsha no I did to Annette I
know but I'm gonna say it's a president
Marsha sorry really again I would say
president wash
happens if you do to really really like
gate really and I'd like to introduce
you to marching cheaply so this would be
how you do but you'd always say the most
important person's name first and then
there's a handshake I should we go
through a little bit of that handshake I
want to do this really quickly so I need
I need a volunteer for the handshake I
need a volunteer
thank you because this does say
something about you as well and about
common courtesy it's all what is your
name please sir
Derek all right there Barbara so this is
what happens and this one happens with
women
all right very often so we're going to
go ahead and just introduce ourselves
how do you do barber line I love it
the Queen's a handshake only the Queen
does this so women don't collapse your
hand and try and grab on that's not a
good thing to be able to do and we're
gonna do another one now
how do you do barber line cultural
differences in this country it is looked
upon that if you have a soft handshake
oh that means that you're not secure oh
that means that you're not assertive
that might not be the case at all but
here in this country it's how it's
perceived in other countries it is a
sign of respect it has nothing to do
with that at all so it's to be conscious
of who it is that you are meaning of
whether or not you want to be able to
have a firmer handshake women tend to
have a softer handshake than men not the
women in the vet school for many years
they down
here's another one Derrick so I am going
to be Bob still Tara yeah like you could
be left out but about how do you do Bob
line and I'll talk about holding on for
a while and then I know you do this I
know because I've had confession so tube
and shake hands
once we little harder with a little
harder Bonecrusher that is not a sign
women you don't need to think I'm gonna
be assertive oh yeah at all and then
there's another one that you can do and
this is my fantasy so I'm going to be a
precedent line your at yeah how do you
do barber line the person of a higher
authority the person who is the host the
person who's welcoming somebody is the
one who then takes the hand and puts it
on the other person's hand
so if you see President Obama effect
tonight is David Union I think is going
on if you see him starting to walk down
the chamber he's shaking hands typically
people do not go ahead and take their
hand in place and I hear he does it for
everybody else now when I was on the
ship Desmond Tutu was on the ships this
is really thrilling and everybody got to
shake just to twos hands so I get my
photo of me shaking his hand and who's
got her hand on Desmond now he did to me
first so I could he had but it's the
idea of it's not like this horrible
thing the intent is is true and I was
responding to his warm handshake but is
that idea of just to simply be aware is
what you want to be able to do so the
other thing and when I we just did it so
some of us do and we're chatting
you've been holding on and so what do I
do
excuse me I just I just I break away and
I pretend that I call thank you very
much those are some things that have to
do with the actual meeting with somebody
you are going to be again in the office
situation I want to talk about emails
because emails are fraught with peril in
ways that we don't really realize so
that when you think about it and there's
a certain breakdown in the communication
so 7% is worse oh I don't know what the
other percentages are I think it's like
47 is toning the rest of its body
language the point is 7% of
communication is words so you think you
got 93% chance of getting misinterpreted
the odds are not in your favor which is
why when you were doing an email and
there are a few things one is to figure
out whether or not it's a one person put
it Phillip put it in his book filled
games he put it is oh my god
oMG which I kind of like and it was you
know the O is the only in other words if
it's just something that is a friendly
conversation then you go ahead and you
do it through email if suddenly there
needs to be a message that's important
is when you start to really look at your
email and a good email a good email is
going to be one where the subject
heading actually is not the subject it's
not hey but it says something cuz people
can then go find it and that when you're
opening it that you have a greeting you
have a salutation I brought an email
then I had from two different adult
lifelong learners one was hi Barbara fun
to hear from our fearless leader yay
thanks for doing this I wasn't able to
open your document though can you send
it another way Thank You Betsy here's
another one
hey how many lifelong learners will be
on this cruise
can you email me a list no it's can you
email me a list are there any more from
Arizona no that's it no thank you
so I immediately you know had all this
opportunities for misinterpretation how
many of you have gotten an email and it
just nags at you does not that what they
mean by that you know what they mean or
you want an email that's really long
it's beautiful to work on all right and
really flame that you put it word so
that you made sure there were no errors
you send it to someone and they respond
back thx
it's not good job before reading it the
idea is that when you have gone the
thoughtful response from shuffle email
you respond in a way that acknowledges
their effort but also rose up the
smartphone what you have 40 characters
on a page is that to realize that a lot
of people are checking their messages so
that if you have something has an
attachment to it you explain in the
subject heading what the emails about
and then in the email body number 40 40
images as it were that you then say
what's in the attachment so a person
will know what's in the attachment
rather making it a mystery you don't
want to as you know have emails that are
emotional there is a new program it's
called tone check anybody know of tone
check so time checking something's been
put out by Microsoft and that it can
basically assess the 200 emotions that
you could potentially be conveyed in
your email message it might be a little
extreme but it's the idea that for the
most part our emails can be entirely
misconstrued this is really the case
when you are talking about something
that is sensitive that is going to be
personal that is about conflict that is
about maybe you want to leave your job
those famous email exchange that was on
all the websites and on the news
stations and he's not heard of it was by
two lawyers and I've heard of this one
or not but basically you've had one
lawyer a candidate
and she was writing and said thank you
very much but I won't be accepting you
offer it wasn't enough money and then I
decided I'm gonna go on my own
and I'm gonna just see how it all shakes
out thank you email back from the person
who interview her I'm sorry to hear
about that I had thought after the two
interviews in our discussion that it was
a an agreement that you'd be with us
unfortunately I have made the stationery
I wish I had known that there was this
much conflict going on I wish you had
said something she writes back well if
you're a lawyer you ought to know how to
write a contract and you should probably
put this on writing and rather than
assumptions and then he wrote back you
know you're young in this industry it's
a small industry you might not want to
be pissing people off and her response
blah blah blah it went all over the
Internet I mean all over the agenda
names everything the idea being that
when you write an email nothing is
confidential nothing is confidential and
so it's that idea of writing with that
tone it's going to be appropriate that
you don't say hey that you said greeting
to me and you you know you have it that
it's going to be that people are gonna
appreciate what it is that you're saying
in the email if it's something that you
should be saying in person or if a
person calls you don't respond to the
email don't we smile on Facebook because
they didn't think that you're avoiding
them is that if someone calls you that
means they want to be able to talk to
you so realize that face to face if a
conflict is going on for the oh my god
oMG you know it is get you know get to
them face to face in other words if
there's any kind of emotion attached to
it then call them up or go right to them
don't think that your e-mails back and
forth that volley is going to be
de-escalating it's only going to
escalate whatever it is going to be
going on so you want to be kind of
careful with that misinterpretation that
so I'm gonna I could I could guys you
probably know I could go on for hours
here I have a little takeout sheet for
you here if there's anything in
particular that you want me to talk
about and if not I will absolutely just
continue going on which is always my way
anyway but is there anything that people
in their minds they see on there they
want me to address and if not I'll just
forge ahead an approach to I don't about
assessing the different protocol that
people have and very often if you mirror
somebody else that you take a look at
how they're sitting it tells you a lot
about their comfort level and every it's
it's gonna change for every single
person but here isn't here's one way of
being able to avoid being rude so once
you actually talk to someone you ask
them so what did you do this weekend oh
I went I went cross-country skiing out
in Ellis Hollow oh I love cross-country
skiing I was that Ravel and I went
cross-country ski it was fabulous and
family you did you bail switching a
conversation so it's now focused on you
and diminishing the other person if I'm
talking to somebody what I'm doing is
that I'm trying as much as I can and I
make mistakes all the time
is trying to listen to what they have to
say ask them questions that are about
them being able to respond to me but I'm
also mirroring their behavior themselves
I would be very different to a fifteen
year old than I am to a 65 year old and
be very different to someone in a
professional setting than I am in a
casual setting but there is a saying by
Maya Angelou and this is paraphrasing
again and and she will say you know
people will not remember winners that
you said people not remember what it is
that you did people remember how you may
even feel so it's that idea can I make
someone feel as though I have
acknowledged them appreciated them it's
not going to be nestled it's going to be
a more formal way of talking if you
really
any more instruction that I would say to
go to Philip Yelena's his book because
he has a y-axis in it and an x-axis and
he's got important not so important
don't care don't give a flying leap and
then it goes ahead and then I'll have
these other little areas of checking and
then you kind of decide also you know
what is gonna make this person
comfortable or uncomfortable and what is
your intent and you know it's all about
that intent you know if I want I can
clearly be snarky and sometimes I will
be just that and I wonder why were that
just that way you know and why did I you
know I say something I wonder why did I
just say what I said it's that idea what
is my intent when I've done something
you know this is the whole idea that
when you have confrontation or you have
interaction with expectation is
manipulation in other words if you're
going in with this intent of deciding to
know somebody exchange information and
you don't have this intent I'm not going
to try to impress them I'm out there for
all these other reasons I'm always kind
of witnessing myself and very often
going my oh my we haven't learned very
much have we oh and it is that idea of
being corrected myself corrected so it's
I know it's it's run a long way of
probably not saying very much which
brings me to but not saying very much
when somebody says something to you
that's rude so I was on the ship and
there's a gentleman on the ship and I
was talking to the group and he said
that is the most I've ever heard someone
to talk about and not say anything
but if you can deflect I didn't insult
him but it was a little self-effacing on
me but you get the point across being
able to manage individuals you know it's
not that challenge of how do you do
something how do you interact with
someone who's difficult and not
escalating it you're not nasally men but
there's another person anyone said to me
barber you know you're gonna quote us
around the ship you are you meant
something else but it was that idea that
he realized that what he just said the
way in which it sounded wasn't his
intent and so he went ahead and
immediately tried to explain if I could
just got an email from him this morning
so I'm thinking of it because he said if
you don't need a letter of reference I
will write it for you I will not write
that you're required any questions on
here I would like to address questions
that people might have please it a whole
section on stories
oh so storytelling it is all about
storytelling and storytelling is that if
you want to be able to get the point
across and this particular juror their
urine whether you're an instructor or
you're a student in to tell a story
because stories are extremely powerful
and stories are going to be the first
thing about a story and there's a book
called the truth of storytelling and
there are four - it's the storytelling
one it has to be authentic and that's be
true to the storyteller so which is why
I like when I do presentations I tell
stories because they're the best way for
you to be able to convey it rather than
me saying be polite have manners tip
like this telling a story is going to be
giving all that so Thomas story has to
be true to the person the second part of
storytelling is that it has to be
relevant to the person to whom you're
speaking because that same story is
going to change for whomever you're
talking to a little bit so that it's
going to be customized for the people
the person that you're going to be
talking to which means that the story
has to also shift
when depending upon what the
circumstance is now when I help students
frame themselves for job interviews it's
all about storytelling
you look at a resume it is all every
line and resume is a movie trailer and
all you're trying to do is they ask me
more you give them a little bit of
information you quantify it outcomes
resume is not along to this a resume is
about the beginning of stories and every
line of a resume you should have a story
behind so if someone asks you something
you can go ahead and tell it but I teach
people how do you tell you how do you
identify your story and then how do you
tell your story so that person's gonna
realize you've convinced them that
whatever you resume said whatever the
point is you trying to make you've just
convinced them and persuaded them
through a story you do it's true where
does it you say that yourself
that's about the storytelling rageth
Amanda it's time to me to write on the
women women if you have to pull it up or
pull it down it is too tight go ahead
and I would I do how do you dress and so
I would always do some few things that
were wrong with my dress usually three
things were wrong well one day I get a
presentation they walked a number of ten
all right then we're going to ask my
mother's pearls and I one person I said
what about my dress she said well it is
on you know it's too baggy on you and I
realized that you know the generations
are very different in their in the way
in which we dress but all I could say is
that they were in an event and even
though this woman is not in the audience
and if I ever cross her I did not do her
service because we were at an event and
she was ample alright the Lord made her
ample and she had it dressed just down
to there and they I say
they'd already been put away I mean that
it was just so distracting so it really
is something for women as far as you
dress to be appropriately dressed women
is host as business it's it's neutral
gender but the problem that women have
being hosts it's on when the check comes
and when the check comes and that you
are their host you're going to find that
very often in an older gentleman is
going to want to take the check and so
the best thing to do for you undergo one
don't worry my age they're thrilled like
take the check oh I put younger women if
you need to be able to take the check
what you do is that during the meal you
excuse yourself and then you have to go
to the host and you have another check
and then in the end of the meal when the
check comes and everyone's lunging to
pay the check
you can say it's already taken care of
and that way you're not in this hassle
of who's going to be taking the check
that is it but for men sometimes it
you're screwed right because I'm all
gender neutral so cuz I mean I don't
open the door does that mean I don't
pull out a chair does that mean I sit
and I stay seated when a woman gets up
well it depends you know if you if your
mother's boy shoot grandmother's voice
your aunt's boys your neighbors boy says
Louie looks to the room you stand right
woman's got to sit down you plus the
chair the thing for men if a woman is
the host depending upon the woman she
might think that if you go ahead you get
the door or you're pulling out the chair
then you're saying that you're the host
you're the alpha male as it were this is
the woman's perception you might be just
doing what your grandmother told you to
do but with the thing to do and you can
always just say they may get the chair
for you and then we can say yes or no
whomever gets to the door first is the
person that opens the door unless there
was a walker
but it's the idea is like being in a
buffet line you'll get one plate right
and then you go look at a line next time
just do this take two plates and take
one plate and give it to the person
behind you not everybody does that you
just do these little acts of grace these
little moments of courtesy and the whole
day gets sort of spotted with all these
little moments of courtesy and it's when
you're being part of the solution not
part of the problem when people are
together so I was talking with hosts I'd
final question please
so they were all interested in that and
mine should be - that wasn't here at
them here say clearly you can't have
that opportunity taste our wines they
are they are terrific and you don't need
to make excuses for the back but you do
something positive as far as the front
but you turn it around I mean you just
turn it around so that you don't
diminish the other person you know
really good after you think of your
wines
yeah we've been we've been at this for a
long time now and sadly it's like come
on fight
you know it's really easy to do that so
you just want to spin that around
because people will do that absolutely
oh so good food preferences and well I'm
upset because food is basically what I
love to talk about anyway something as
far as food goes if you have your vegan
vegetarian gooey lactose intolerant you
go through it and you need to go to an
event I alter the whole
story but the bottom line is a range
tort beforehand all right call ahead of
time because a bank would call ahead of
time if it's a restaurant call ahead of
time do something so you're not looking
like high maintenance because you're
gonna find that when you a perdu like
you're being taken out for any kind of a
business lunch interview lunch anything
like that people are not taking you out
because they think that you need to be
fed they are taking you out because they
want to see what you were like in a
social situation how is it that you're
responding to other people you know the
server is the person if you're to
banquet and they're serving 25 people
all at once in a banquet hall you can
I'm sorry I don't eat chicken and almost
edit a piece of commercial you take out
the credit card everyone is using the
credit card one person takes out cash
and everybody falls over everybody else
you stop the rhythm of the night
well the same thing and a banquet if
Oren in a restaurant if you don't do
that pre-planning doesn't mean that you
should eat food you don't want to eat
but you do want to be able to just make
sure that you're not imposing on other
people and the last thing because 110 is
112 so we're gonna have to end it I know
that is it to use humor to please it
when in doubt not if someone else's
expense sarcasm is a very dangerous road
to go on because sarcasm always has a
little bit of cruelty to it whether or
not you think it does or not it always
has a little Peck that is diminishing
somebody else but if you can do things
that not this is my last story is that I
do triathlons when I start doing
triathlons I all these people have
buffed and we all were putting on wet
suits and I am a lake and I go behind
the bush and I put on my wetsuit I come
out and everyone is staring at me but
what what they say right there's no way
these things come
you know people very often think that
particularly people who are shy there's
never been shy introvert it's a whole
other conversation
we all are shy they are very concerned
other other people view them and how
they judge them so that it's in the last
at them I think they're laughing at them
it's mortifying to them so it's like
take yourself a little more lightly and
have a sense of humor about yourself
when you go forward so that you really
can go ahead and apply what Maya says
and what everyone else says
but it's that idea of being of benefit
not focusing so much on yourself but
making sure the people of whom you are
speaking are feeling as though they're
the only person in the room and that you
would give them your full attention and
your appreciation
saying thank you hi not going back I was
a couple more ajusshi find a new so
she's gonna have to get a bread but
whatsoever does something nice for you
you know invite you to their home you
know drink something always bring a gift
when someone has done something that is
exceptional and out of the ordinary and
is inviting you to breakfast or
something but don't go empty-handed
so someone said you mean like bring it I
say that you know George and sometimes
if you like Smuckers people who don't
know how to cross-country see I don't
know how to cross-country ski I think if
somebody beginner lessons and she
doesn't allow people to go there and she
is teaching as though it's the first
time she's ever taught somebody up in
her life and so I said thank you
- I extend you graduate or someone you
have to go bake bread but you do
something nice for someone to show that
appreciation now go
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu